[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in jeff duncan
columnist for the athletic covering the
saints he also wrote a book
peyton and brees which came out last
fall goes into great detail about
drew his relationship with sean the team
and the city
all right jeff where are we with drew
brees
and his future well we're in uh
weight mode dan uh you know it's kind of
peculiar but if you know drew brees
uh he doesn't do anything uh that isn't
thorough and i think he's taken a
thorough uh
amount of time to consider this big
decision for him
but everything i've been able to gather
he is retiring i've not talked to one
person inside the saints organization
that
doesn't believe he's retiring and i
think he tipped his hand
last month when he agreed to reduce his
base salary from
25 million down to one million dollars
that that's
letting you know he's not going to see
any of that money in the in the fall
because he's going to retire so
i think we're all just in wait and see
mode when they're going to make the
official announcement
zero percent chance is that what you're
saying uh no i wouldn't go that far
i would i would say it's it's very low
though
you know drew acted like a player that
was done at the end of this season i
mean if
all my interactions with him you could
just see it on his face
he he knew that his time had come i mean
he spent
then he spent an hour and a half after
their playoff loss
uh you know in the playoffs to the bucks
on the superdome field
with his children with his wife brittany
running past patterns just soaking up
the moment i don't think that was by
accident so i guess
there is a possibility he's rethought it
and and considered coming back
i haven't talked to him lately but i
would just be surprised with how the
season ended and
everything internally everyone's on the
same page that drew's moving on
but i wonder what the local reaction
would be because
it feels like they've already moved on
to the possibility of russell wilson
and as a fallback plan we got taysom
hill and james winston
would saints fans react favorably if
drew brees was coming back no matter
what the salary was
that's a great question i don't know how
saints fans would react i think
everyone's moved on
i know saints coaches have already had
conversations
with jameis winston about him taking the
torch
so clearly they've moved on and they are
expecting drew brees to retire
uh i don't know how the fans would react
because i think drew brees
last year was so disappointing
especially how he finished
in that last game against the bucks
three interceptions the most in his
playoff career i think people see that
father tom has caught up to him and
they're kind of ready for something
different as great as drew brees has
been
in in his career here what was the
reaction when russell wilson named the
saints as one of the four teams if he
was traded
are you kidding me if they could have
had a mardi gras parade here for russell
wilson
we could we could violate all the covid
restrictions
i think the mayor certainly would have
cleared that and deshaun watson's
another one any big name
quarterback uh you know visions of super
bowl championships are dancing in the
minds of saints fans
as you know dan this is a very
passionate
nfl market i mean it's amazing how
popular the saints are here and
and they've had such a long history of
poor quarterback play until drew brees
came around and now i don't think they
know how to react because they don't
know what life is like without
an elite quarterback at least the new
generation of saints fans
do they have the assets to acquire a
russell wilson
or deshaun watson well they could make
it happen if they had to but it would be
very difficult they're way over the
salary cap mickey loomis and kai harley
are geniuses at manipulating
that cap but i think even they would be
challenged
to bring in a quarterback with an elite
salary they'd have to move some people
and somehow they'd have to get somebody
to take taysom hill who they're paying
a lot of money to at quarterback i mean
right now even without bringing in
another quarterback with drew brees
retiring
and and jason hill they're counting 26
million dollars toward the quarterback
position
so it'll be very difficult i think to
bring in someone that's already on a big
salary
that hasn't stopped us from wishful
reporting here
right no it's the silly season i mean
that's the way
it operates this time of year and i will
say this though the one thing you have
to consider and i know
you've had sean payton on your show many
times sean payton
does not believe in rebuilding years and
transition years i mean the window
is always open for him and he is going
to be aggressive
so if he can do something to make it
happen
he's going to push mickey loomis to make
it happen that's just how sean thinks
but i really believe he thinks they can
win with the quarterbacks they have in
the building
i really believe that conversations i've
had with him i don't i don't know if
it's going to happen but i think he
believes it and i think that's what
matters
jeff thanks for joining us hope you're
well we appreciate your time
yeah anytime dan thanks for having me on
that's jeff duncan a frequent guest on
the show his book peyton and brees came
out last fall
goes into great detail about drew his
relationship with his coach
the team and the city